>> YOU'RE WATCHING DETECTIVE TV.
AT 9:00 P.M. IT'S KEITH BLACK
DETECTIVE, BUT, FIRST, IT'S A
BRAND NEW HOLIDAY SPECIAL WITH
YOUR FAVORITE CRIME FIGHTING
DUO.
>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN SANTA IS
KIDNAPPED BY ONE OF CHICAGO'S
MOST NOTORIOUS GANGS?
IS CHRISTMAS CANCELED?
NOT WITH THESE TWO ON THE CASE.
THEY ARE HARD AS IRON.
THEY ARE ROUGH AS GUTS.
AND IF YOU'VE BEEN NAUGHTY, THEY
WON'T BE NICE.
IT'S DYKE AND FATS, SAVE
CHRISTMAS.
STARRING DUTCH PLAINS AS OFFICER
LEZ DYK OWI TZ AND VELVY
O'MALLEY AS OFFICER FATSERELLI.
THIS CHRISTMAS THEY'RE GETTING
SANTA BACK BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
EVEN IF THEY HAVE TO KICK EVERY
BUTT IN TOWN.
IT'S DYDE AND FATS.
SAVE CHRISTMAS.
HYAH!
>> YOU TWO DID IT AGAIN.
SANTA CLAUS SAVES CHRISTMAS.
>> I GUESS WE DID A PRETTY GOOD
JOB.
I THINK YOU MEAN GREAT JOB,
FATS.
>> SHE'S RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
OFFICER DYKOWITZ AND FATSORELLI
WHERE.
>> THANKS FOR USING OUR NAMES.
>> YOU'RE TWO DAMN FINE COPS,
FOR BROADS.
>> WAIT.
WHAT?
>> BACK TO THE WOMEN THING?
>> WE'RE BACK TO THAT?
>> WE'RE PAST THAT.
>> NO, NO, WE'RE PAST IT!
NO!
♪♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]